bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver au sommaire de ça vous regarde
ce soit les recettes d'alain minc pour
le monde d'après l'économiste et ses
listes qui susurre à l'oreille des
manuels macron est notre invité fil
rouge pendant une heure il publie chez
grasset mais président avec lui on
parlera de la crise économique
la casse sociale jusqu'où le nouveau
capitalisme vraiment l'indépendance
stratégique des mots ou du concret avec
un dialogue inédit avec un restaurateur
qui se bat contre la faillite et puis
nous évoquons bien sûr la figure
tutélaire du général de gaulle en ce 80e
anniversaire de l'appel du 18 juin 1940
emmanuel macron était ce matin au mont
valérien cet après midi à londres pour
des cérémonies exceptionnel pourquoi le
général reste le modèle absolu pourquoi
tous s'en réclament
à droite comme à gauche alain minc
laurent joffrin le patron de libération
ce sera la fiche de la dernière partie
de cette émission voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti hashed accès vers
n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
l'image du jour ce sont donc ces
cérémonies d'hommage au général de
gaulle 80 ans jour pour jour après
l'appel du 18 juin 1940 vous le voyez
emmanuel macron mont valérien ce matin
l'union sacrée le temps d'une journée
pour célébrer l'héroïque rébellion du
général contre l'envahisseur allemand et
contre l'armistice du maréchal pétain
bonsoir alain minc bon choix c'est
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans votre livre mais
président chez grasset vous avez un
chapitre le premier consacré au général
de gaulle on va en parler mais vous
comprenez qu'on est encore le frisson 40
ans 81 ans après heureusement qu'on a le
frisson si on n'avait pas le frisson ça
veut dire qu'on n'aurait aucune
conscience de l'histoire et on n'aurait
aucune conscience du miracle que fut
hélas pas lieu de 40 et la résistance et
la place de la france parmi les
vainqueurs qu'alors qu'elle a démarré
cette guerre commune vaincu absolue et
pourtant vous même n'avez pas été
gaulliste en tout cas pas au départ vais
non parce que comme mes parents étaient
communistes j'ai été élevé au biberon
l'antigaullisme et c'est ce que je
raconte au début de ce livre au fond
j'ai fait une découverte poste
postérieure du gaullisme et je me suis
fait le reproche d'avoir mis longtemps à
comprendre qu'ils avalaient qu'il y
avait là quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel voire d'un peu magique
revenir on a du temps pour le faire
vous connaissez lacoste et donc je le
connaître c'est parti c'est lui qui
dresse votre portrait si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour myriam bonsoir des pannes
bonsoir vous avez vous compris
d'alarmant si j'ai bien compris myriam
on l'a quand même la chance de recevoir
aujourd'hui dans ce studio
le conseiller le plus réputé du
tout-paris économiques et politiques
alors rien demandé mais pourquoi tous
les gens qui ont une influence en france
demandent des conseils à la main
pourquoi ben jacques il a au moins aussi
bien au moins deux qualités qui nous
font défaut myriam heures premièrement
il est très très très intelligent alors
vous vexez pas myriam je sais vous à
d'été sciences po moi même je vis
mention assez bien au bac mais à la main
c'est quand même la catégorie au dessus
ce qui est quand même sorti major de sa
promotion de l'ena 1,75
ça veut dire qu'il est aussi intelligent
que laurent wauquiez
il a lui aussi est sorti major en 2001
enfin vous voyez le niveau est
impressionnant je vois la deuxième
qualité equal alors deuxième qualité qui
nous fait défaut c'est qu'il a un carnet
d adresses monstrueux dire qu'il peut
appeler mais quand il en a envie
n'importe quelle personne en france qui
a un minimum d'influents d'ailleurs que
quand je le vois en face de moi un mec
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai toujours une
mauvaise pensée qui traverse l'esprit et
si je pouvais lui jouait son portable
devrait compter les couper ou disons ce
que fait cette distraction le mois
pendant ce temps là je m'approche et aux
jupes hic le téléphone serment je vous
assure je sais pas si vous vous imaginez
mais c'est quand même fascinant de tenir
dans les mains un téléphone avec lequel
on pourrait appeler mais n'importe quel
président de la république et vous allez
à haisnes comme nico hop vous pouvez
joindre sarkozy aime comme manu hop vous
pouvez appeler macron f comme flamby hop
vous pouvez appeler hollande et or c'est
exactement pareil pour le monde des
affaires
par exemple j'avais envie de parler un
milliardaire ils sont tous temps son
portable
vous pouvez appeler bolloré pour
l'appeler pinault arnault même xavier
niel celui que vous voulez bon alors
vous n'êtes pas vrai qu'ici vous aviez
ce fameux téléphone si précieux je sais
pas bien même pour le boulot par exemple
si alain minc nous prêtait son téléphone
lui pardonner nous traiter ouais envoyé
par exemple par sms
emmanuel macron bah ouais me pons rex
offrait un service demain qu il nous
répondra un arrêt des infos par exemple
on mettrait comme message tu en penses
quoi de le drian à matignon et puis
après on attend on voit s'il dit tu
commences à me saouler avec le drian ou
si nous dit
plutôt t'inquiète pas il est dans la
short list et ça serait une info pour
nous je veux dire même on pourrait
peut-être même se seraient pas bien non
pour en faire un usage personnel on
pourrait vous cherchez le téléphone de
définir note le pdg de france
télévisions qui enverra un message
salut delphine j'ai fait lcp la
présentatrice est parfois lieu qu anne
sophie lapix
gros bisous on se revoit quand tu veux
et voilà et votre carrière est lancée
bon alors ça veut dire qu en un seul
message alain minc
voilà est sûr d'être entendu son
influence est à ce point d'en faire
faire une carrière comme tu dis est il
possible à défaire le truc sur ce que
les gg des conseils - à 10 des cas la
main
mais l'avantagé ils sont gratuits
d'envoyer pouvant profiter directement
parce que je vous conseille pas de
questions qui fâchent pendant les
interviews il ressort énervé du studio
en son sein des téléphones étaient là
c'est bertrand de l'est le président de
lcp puis hop ça y est le truc dans la
main la canarde influence c'est que même
terre qu'on n'ose pas contrariant monde
aux pales contrarié parce qu'on sait que
s'il vous a grip batum est plus
compliqué non au projet en fait pas trop
lane
franchement moi ça un petit ou trop
désolidarise totalement de ses trois
marques nationales
comment ça qu'est ce que voulait
sous-entend que se pose une question
avec al-qaïda peut-être moins
d'affluence qu'avant c'est ça que vous
voulez dire non mais myriam 1 si vous le
provoquer ce qu'il va se passer quoi le
téléphone trois coups de fil votre
carrière brisée donc réfléchissez donc
un garde de dire n'importe quoi bon à
l'écouté pam sur un cas je sais que vous
avez gardé votre influence est je le
rappelle à ceux qui l'auraient oublié
vous est celui qui a mis le pied à
l'étrier emmanuel macron pour démarrer
chez rothschild nous avait interrogé
là-dessus puis vous aviez dit vous avez
vu tout de suite toutes ses qualités
extrait célèbre qu'on regarde parce
qu'il était exceptionnellement charmant
et intelligent et que ce sont les
qualités d'un bouquet d'affaires vous
manqués d'affaires doit être intelligent
souple rapide et si peut être en plus
charmant que c'est quand même un métier
de
est évident et c'est une qualité et il
les avait tout bien encore une qualité
dans la main que nous n'avons pas
forcément il a un flair incontesté pour
repérer les talents alors donc mon
conseil me regarde concert gratuit
on se concentre sur cette émission s'il
y en a du talent vous inquiétez pas
anormal à s'en rendre compte il va
sortir dans le tout paris il répétait
tout le monde y sont formidables sur lcp
et a les bras demander une augmentation
je veux aller à venir vous installer
monsieur vous vous dites vous voulez un
verre d'eau voulais quelque chose vous
m'aider ce côté médias d'un nouveau
genre me séduit évident
c'est finalement avec erwan y est décrit
un homme d'un grand pouvoir vous assumez
non mais c'est ce qu'il a fait
évidemment excessif tout à fait gentil
mais vous savez moi j'ai eu des
biographies contre moi pour dire
exactement l'inversé
donc je fais la pondération entre son
carburant à la main qu'est ce que cette
influence justement où le carburant
c'est de conjurer le temps c'est tout
quand j'irai voter ch'ti alors que il
peut organiser des dîners avec un
réellement tous les patrons de presse
qu'est ce qui vous fait courir de ne pas
m'ennuyer
voilà il voulait jamais eu le sentiment
pour y être une sorte de tour de
contrôle du milieu des affaires
présenter les gens faire et défaire ça
dans l'ombre
vous savez c'est un peu paradoxal parce
que j'ai un métier de banc de conseil où
je suis la discrétion même est un métier
public ou comme vous le verrez je suis
aussi cash qu'il est possible de l'être
on l'a entendu des armes de l'hégire des
médecins le banquier bon bah on va
s'adresser
comment comment vous aimez le mieux vous
définir parce que j'avais tellement de
casquette je suis un vrp multicartes
ah ben on va très bien alors c'est comme
ces lieux je vais m'adresser oui oui oui
oui à l'économiste que vous êtes pour
commencer parce qu'on va on va essayer
de comprendre un peu ce qui nous ce qui
nous arrive à les chiffres sont
extrêmement violent on a des dates déjà
détruit 11 points de notre richesse
nationale c'est c'est colossal
et pourtant et je vous fait réagir après
les nouvelles ne sont pas si mauvaises
que ça ah bon soir raphaël legendre
j'espère que vous êtes avec nous depuis
votre
webcams est ce qu'il est avec nous le
voilà bon soit rafael chroniqueur pour
cette émission et journalistique ce
papier peint derrière raphaël c'est une
fausse baby hôtel à l'opinion
c'est une salle de réunion de l'opinion
adacore alors lindsay a dressé hier le
premier bilan de l'économie française
post déconfinement quels sont les
premiers enseignements d'écouter les
premières nouvelles sont plutôt bonnes
en tout cas c'est moins grave que prévu
l'insee indiqué hier effectivement que
la récession au deuxième trimestre ne
sera pas de 20% mais de -17% alors le
chiffre est colossal mais regardez ce
graphique on voit l'évolution mois après
mois le pil s'est effondrée au mois
d'avril - 29% mais ça repart assez vite
depuis au mois de juin on est à -12%
l'insee parle d'une reprise économique
très nette
effectivement un mois après le
déconfinement l'économie tourne à peu
près à 90%
et ça c'est une très bonne nouvelle cela
veut dire que les entreprises se portent
déjà mieux on peut dire ça alors ça va
mieux après la reprise est quand même
bien différente selon les secteurs je
vous donne quelques chiffres par exemple
la fabrication de matériels de transport
l'activité reste toujours en baisse de
38% par rapport à la normale dans
l'hébergement la restauration qui repart
à peine on est toujours à -35%
d'activité et même si la construction
est bien repartie elle est encore à -34
%
donc ça reste quand même difficile mais
vous avez d'autres secteurs comme
l'immobilier
l'alimentaire les boissons qui sont
quasiment revenu à la normale donc ça
aussi c'est encore une fois une bonne
nouvelle et la consommation
est-ce qu'en face les français
conservent ou pas et oui la consommation
c'est très important c'est un pilier
majeur de la croissance française et
cette consommation est bien là très
nettement rebondi on est quasiment
revenu à la normale
la consommation n'est qu'à moins 7% au
mois de juin après une chute de - 30% en
avril on était tous confinés chez nous
on ne pouvait plus consommée
la salle est reparti très nettement
depuis déconfinement les biens
manufacturés comme les voitures ou
l'électroménager par exemple sont même
en très nette hausse
ils savent autre part très fort tant
mieux il ya encore quelques biens de
consommation les carburants transport ou
ou la restauration on en a parlé qui
peine toujours qui donc pas retrouvé
leur niveau d'avant crise et à l'armée
nous avons des raisons d'être optimiste
pourquoi parce que durant confinement
les français ont épargné 60 milliards
d'euros en dévoue compte c'est colossal
cet argent il va falloir maintenant le
dépenser si possible en produits
français ce sera la clé du rebond au
deuxième
au deuxième semestre à une condition
bien sûr c'est que les ménages ne
craignent pas de se retrouver au chômage
d'ici noël la consommation est
étroitement lié à la confiance des
ménages qui est elle mêle étroitement
liée au niveau de l'emploi et sur ce
point malheureusement et bien l'inconnue
reste entier merci beaucoup
raphaël alain minc est ce que vous êtes
optimiste comme le montre l'insee avec
ces premiers chiffres au contraire les
dégâts seront pires comme le dit
d'ailleurs dominique strauss-kahn ce
matin dans les échos
bien pire qu'en 2008 je crois que c'est
d'une nature tout à fait différente et
je suis très content d'entendre ce que
votre chroniqueur a dit je pense que la
situation est très difficile mais
qu'elle est moins dramatique qu'on a pu
le craindre est une des raisons
au fond on s'est tous dit là
reprise sera chaotique s'il n'y a pas de
vaccin s'il n'y a pas de traitement
mais on avait oublié qu'il ya une
possibilité une troisième possibilité
c'est que le virus décide si je puis
dire d'hiberner en été et donc d'une
certaine façon la peur a disparu et la
disparition de la peur entraîne
nécessairement un rebond de l'activité
je crois qu'il ya une très grande
différence en 2008 c'est à la fois moins
graves et plus grave
moins grave pourquoi en 2008 le système
capitaliste aurait pu disparaître on a
été un millimètre a disparue sur blaye
n'en a jamais été question
le système capitaliste s'est mis à
l'arrêt en revanche il est clair qu'en
2008 la récession a été pour la france 2
- 2 et demi pour cent et que au mieux
au mieux elle sera cette année de - 8 -
neuf donc les conséquences instantanée
économisés par son couple et sa jusqu'à
-20 non non non non globalement et après
ce qu'on a entendu on tournera retour de
sa veut dire concrètement pour c'est
pour les gens qui nous regardent d'une
reprise en v
en gros on combine ya à l'été puis à
partir de mon temps là on creuse pas il
vous l'a dit on ne creuse ça dépend des
secteurs non mais globalement c'est
mieux que ce qu'on pensait alors il faut
espérer une chose c'est que ce jeu virus
accepte d'hiberner aussi pendant l'hiver
c'est la peur du virus disparaît c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais si c'est
remplacé par la peur du chômage
l'idée qu' il émettait cette hypothèse
raphaël disait avec la peur du chômage
peut-être que on sera moins en inciter à
consommer on se dira ça c'est exact et
que l'économie pâtira aussi est que
l'épargné restera dans les bandes oui
mais bien sûr que un chômage de masse
entraîne de la prudence pèse sur
l'activité ça c'est une certitude mais
c'est pas la même chose qu'un pays qui
est aussi entre la mise à l'arrêt ou le
à la mise en régime de 2000 vitesse
c'est fondamental d'espérer qu'il n'y
aura pas de deuxième main que c'est
vraiment fondamente peut pas se payer
deux fois cette histoire
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon il
faudra quand même la ré écrire cette
histoire comment un moment donné
pourquoi on a pris une décision et une
once et pas la france c'est le monde
occidental globalement une partie même
du monde non occidental d'arrêter le
système et de labeur sur la peur qui
nous va lui laisser la peur et c'est un
choix implicite qui est lié à la manière
dont fonctionnent nos sociétés on a
préféré éviter des morts visible quitte
à faire des morts
invisible faudra plus de mort invisible
évidemment quand vous faites moins 10%
sur un pays développé ça veut dire le
commerce extérieur fait moins 15%
ça veut dire que les pays pauvres non
plus on leur budget en déséquilibre
ça veut dire que la pauvreté s'aggrave
dans notre pays vous parlez de pauvreté
vous parlez de le monde personnes qui
vont mourir à quoi que la constante et
de la bourse plonge natale quand elle se
transmet au monde peut développer ça
fait des morts que quelques bénéfices
pour vous du confinement total est
mauvais c'est pas un calcul comme ici je
pense que d'une certaine façon on a un
moment eu un coup de chaud 6 cuillères
collectivement pas la france l'ours
intéressant de se demander pourquoi on a
eu ce coup de chaud je crois que parce
que la raison principale est qu'on
admire les chinois
si c'était les japonais on n'aurait pas
eu de pouce aux îles n'admire ou pas les
japonais on peut parfois les cram et la
valeur de la vie que les chinois les
plus intelligents les plus dominants les
plus impérialistes si confine il faut
confiné on a fait quand même on peut se
demander qui aurait pu arrêter cette
marche à la biba a conseillé peut-être
une ou est ce que vous avez donné des
conseils parce que sérieusement je dis
sérieusement est-ce que vous vous aviez
des hommes avaient des noms et un homme
au monde qui pouvait arrêter cette
affaire qui n'est pas que française
c'était un président des états unis
respectez le problème c'est que trump a
dit probablement une des choses et plus
au départ mais parce que ça venait trump
s'était disqualifiée compte tenu de son
comportement erratique fou inacceptable
insupportable
il a dit faisons attention le remède
peut être pire que le mal
c'était une phrase très intelligente
obama président des états unis aurait
dit faisons attention le remède peut
être pire que le mal on offert était
proportionné le conflit mais il
s'agissait pas dire on continue comme
avant mais question la valeur de la vie
elles existent dans ce débat aussi il ya
une question éthique ça n'est pas simple
mais non mais c'est très charmant dû
dire ça quand même fier des non non non
mais attendez quand je suis pas du tout
d'accord parce que quand emmanuel macron
a dit dimanche on a préféré la vie à
l'économie
oui c'est vrai en faisant la france
telle qu'elle est le monde entier a
décidé de faire des centaines de
milliers de morts de pauvreté dans
tiers-monde
avec la baisse de son niveau de vie donc
on n'a pas préféré la vie à l'économie
on a il faut le savoir préférez la vie
dans les pays riches à la vie et à la
mort invisible dans les pays dans les
pays pauvres
je dis pas qu'on pouvait faire autre
chose mais j'ai eu soin et mouillant au
moins lucide
arrêtons de nous gargariser et je ne
parle pas des dégâts indirects de cette
affaire si vous quoi bon le confinement
en effet au cap ferret pour un cadre
supérieur qui s'occupe deux heures de
ses enfants et le reste du temps fait
six conférences sur zoom c'est pas
exactement la même chose que le
confinement dans un dans trente mètres
carrés à 5 avec des gens qui vivent à
pernes évidemment mais était un scénario
à l'italienne comme on a vu dans les
hôpitaux de lombardie des hôpitaux
saturés vous pensez mais les gîtes
ailleurs que ce point là elle est ex
otages italiens qu'on gérait avec un
courage extraordinaire cette affaire ce
pays que l'on dit indiscipliné a été
plus disciplinés que les autres pays
au début nous ne sommes pas brillant
parce que on a 10 ans et les italiens
isaure mauvais système sanitaire on
oublie que la région où cette affaire
s'est produite est la région la plus
riche d'europe
la région turin milan et plus risque la
plus riche des régions allemandes
donc c'est un pays hyper développé et
ils ont
agi avec à une violence avec de manière
extrêmement raisonnable et professionnel
et je pense que je pense leur système
sanitaire dans le nord de l'italie n'est
pas forcément la tenue un bon claude
mais il faut bien se mesurer qu'une
partie du confinement et la manière dont
on a géré ld confinement était liée
uniquement aux lits de réanimation que
nous avions beaucoup moins nombreux par
exemple aujourd'hui non aujourd'hui les
pays et les pays riches n'accepterait
plus le confinement total donc c'est
fini c'est fini
alors je voudrais qu'on passe au saas et
ça c'est le diagnostic
je voudrais qu'on passe aux solutions
les recettes d'alain minc pour éviter
justement l'effondrement de l'économie
j'imagine que vous soutenez les mesures
prises de court terme
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire donnez
donnez donnez soutenir soutenir toutes
les entreprises tous les salariés sans
conditions sans contrebande d'abord je
crois qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
pour ça que je n'étais m jamais à l'aise
avec la comparaison qui a été trop
souvent fait avec la crise de 1929
si en 1930 les gouvernements et les
banques centrales avaient fait ce que
les gouvernements et les banques
centrales d'aujourd'hui ont fait on
aurait probablement éviter l'engrenage
fatal qui a conduit à hitler donc dans
des périodes aussi populiste aussi
démagogique il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont les gouvernements
de tous les grands pays
les banques centrales de toutes les
grandes zones monétaires ont fait le
boulot et vous fait parfaitement le
boulot est de ce point de vue le système
a tenu parce que ils ont en effet
injecté de l'argent parce que la banque
centrale européenne et pas à passer
outre à toutes ces règles pour faire ce
qu'il fallait à ce moment là la planche
à billets non mais la planche à billets
avaient très bien mais très bien mais
c'était la seule réponse intelligente
qu'on pouvait faire alors après il ya la
suite
alors j'espère gagner alors d'abord il
va falloir faire des aides
parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'entreprises endommagés ce sont comme
des bateaux dont la qui a été atteinte
donc il va falloir faire des fonds
propres dans quelle proportion ne sais
pas encore
veut dire accepter d'être remboursé
quand on prête de l'argent c'est accéder
à la plage sur ne pas être annulé le cas
échéant
alors ça vaut au niveau microéconomique
et il ya un énorme enjeu
macroéconomiques qui est de savoir
comment c'est très con pas dans ce que
je vais aborder très compliqué mais
c'est très fondamentale comment nous
allons traiter la dette que les états
ont fabriqué pour répondre aux que vides
je suis de ceux qui pensent que en
réalité la dette qu vide
elle a été achetée par la banque
centrale et bien c'est d'être là
uniquement c'est d'être là il faut la
transformer comme mieux contre une dette
à très très long terme à un demi pour
cent sur 50 ans alors je sais que c'est
contre elle veut dire qu'il faudra la
rembourser quand même même si on létale
dans le temps la question je vous pose
je voulais la pause et plus tard mais
maintenant qu'on dit et vous avez vu le
papier dominique strauss-kahn dans les
échos ce matin
lui dit qu'il ne faut pas forcément
rembourser to be la dette mais
simplement les intérêts de la dette bien
sixième de rang mais on pense exactement
le banal jeu moi j'ai écrit dans le même
journal que la logique aurait voulu même
d'annuler cette partie là de la dette
sauf que les traités l'interdisent et
que nos amis allemands ont déjà accepté
beaucoup de choses contraires à leur
discipline et à leur doctrine et qui à
un moment il faut pas que pour vous on a
fait comme mélenchon qui réclamait
longtemps l'annulation de donner des
noms mais je sais on dit mais on dit que
je pense que mélenchon d'abord jean luc
mélenchon est un homme intelligent les
informer la seule chose c'est que lui
veut annuler toutes les dettes
moi je dis simplement on n'annule pas la
dette pris celle de la banque mondiale
ou la banane huile la part de dette des
états qui a été créé maintenant et qui
est dans les coffres de la banque
centrale
c'est clair tout on paye la dette privée
parce que si on ne paye pas la dette
privée on foule système en l'air c'est
la petite différence entre jean luc
mélenchon hébrard le système allez je
voudrais vous interroger sur le monde
d'après parce qu'il ya des solutions
d'urgence mais déjà beaucoup
d'économistes part d'un changement
complet de modèle économique emmanuel
macron a promis d'ailleurs des décisions
de rupture sans précisions pour l'heure
peut-être
vous en savez un peu plus on est allé
interroger jacques attali et thomas
porcher qui à leur manière défendent
deux modèles que tout oppose regarder
notre modèle économique et il a repensé
à la main qui n'est pas le seul à donner
ses recettes
tous les économistes théorise l'aprec
ovide et jacques attali est thomas
porcher nous ont livré leurs recettes
pour s'en sortir on injecte de l'argent
aujourd'hui pour soutenir une économie
qui est finalement défaillante mais on
ne fait pas les les réformes de fond
pour changer le modèle économique
or si on ne change pas le modèle
économique n'est pas on sera confronté à
d'autres crises thomas porcher s'était
penché sur la transformation de notre
modèle avant la crise dans les délais
c'est moi je base est une nouvelle
économie sur deux critères l'état
stratège qui pourrait organiser
notamment la transition énergétique et
la relocalisation d'une grosse partie
nos industries c'était écrit noir sur
blanc dans mon livre puis l'état social
l'état social jeu proposé que l'on mette
grosso modo 40 milliards par an 40
milliards par an dans le service public
la petite enfance les hôpitaux en
premier lieu bien sûr l'éducation et c
est parti sur l'investissement notamment
dans la rénovation des bâtiments les
énergies renouvelables et une partie de
la rue localisation dans industrie
pendant le confinement
jacques attali a appelé à un nouveau
modèle économique l'économie de la vie
pour réorienter progressivement notre
économie vers des secteurs prioritaires
que j'appelle l'économie de la beach et
à l'ensemble des secteurs qui sont ceux
qu'on a vus d'une façon criante comme
les crs ou développer mais à laquelle il
faut se concentrer au détriment d'autres
secteurs ces secteurs sont des secteurs
d'évidence la santé l'hygiène
l'alimentation l'agriculture l'éducation
la recherche la culture l'information la
sécurité la démocratie les énergies
propres les déchets les digital la
distribution l'assurance le crédit le
commerce au sens large et quelques
autres secteurs
pour ces deux économistes la
transformation est nécessaire et il
appelle rapidement aux changements une
économie sous morphine j'ai une fois
sous morphine ça va deux fois sous
morphine dans les morts
l'économie sous morphine ne sais pas si
c'est possible un temps mais on le paye
le prix là il va falloir vraiment
réfléchir un autre modèle et ne va pas
falloir juste on va dire colmater un
petit peu les brèches à droite et à
gauche et penser que tout peut continuer
comme avant
je pense que là il ya une partie de la
population qui subira encore le système
et qui pourra cette fois ci ne pas
l'accepter si j'étais seulement
observateurs et si je ne pensais pas
pouvoir aider par ce que je dis ce que
je fais à changer les choses je serai
pessimiste parce que la tendance
naturelle des hommes c'est de dire qu'on
vient de vivre cachés cauchemar
réveillons nous faisons comme avant
c'était mieux avant non on oublie que là
c'est le avant qui a provoqué ça vous
allez me dire vers quel modèle votre
coeur balance alain minc
je vous salue et je vous d'accueil
stéphane manigold bon soit vous êtes
restaurateur à paris vous avez une
structure établissements vous allez
échangé avec alain minc dans un instant
puisque vous avez les deux mains dans le
cambouis mais pour rebondir d'abord sur
sur ce sujet jacques attali qui nous dit
surtout ne pas répéter au fond ce monde
d'avant ce modèle économique d'avant je
suis d'accord ni avec l'un ni avec
l'autre
malgré ma grande estime et amitié pour
jacques attali il faut pas penser qu'on
va réécrire l'histoire que deux modèles
va être extrêmement différent et je vais
vous en donner un exemple tout le monde
dit le monde ne sera plus mondialisé
comme il l'est en fait
regardez il y a trois mondialisation il
ya d'abord la mondialisation numérique
celle là elle s'est accrue et on l'a
bien senti qu est-ce que nous serions
devenus 100 numérique ya la
mondialisation financière
celle là elle demeure telle qu'elle a
été et personne ne met en cause la libre
circulation des mouvements de capitaux
même jean luc mélenchon puis à la
mondialisation des biens et services
alors elle sera écornée à la marge oui
en effet on fera en sorte que 80 % notre
paracétamol ne viennent plus de 600 à 10
son trait président lundi
ça va être fait mais c'est pas un
changement de nature pas de la
mondialisation n'a pas démondialiser
comme idée mais le nouveau capitalisme
bah c'est pas mon expression c'est celle
de bruno le maire qui en parle
régulièrement y compris dans des
cénacles internationaux
vous y croyez ou pas mais le capitalisme
a commencé à muter bien avant cet
accident c'est la grande différence avec
2008 que j'ai essayé de souligner tout à
l'heure en 2008 le modèle capitaliste
était en cause et il a failli mourir là
c'est un accident gravissime mais c'est
un accident
donc qui ne changent pas qui ne vient
pas du moderne on peut palier on peut
pas dire que le virus est un produit du
capitalisme le virus il
il a traversé les millénaires et le
nouveau bouquin de jacques attali a au
départ
l'économie de la vie à une recension
historique de ce que sont les pandémies
rien la seule chose que ça nous montre
c'est que en 2020 on est aussi exposé à
certains égards qu'on l'était à la fin
du moyen-âge
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec le modèle
économique ce sont des faits
d'environnement et des catastrophes on
en vivra d'autres la vraie réflexion
c'est comment nous fabriquons notre
résistance je n'aime pas le mot
résilience qui paraît-il le mot le
nouveau mot chic qu'elle nous fabriquons
notre résistance aux crises qui vient
est en fait on combat toujours en
refaisant l'actrice d'avant je vous
donne un exemple après la crise
financière
on a bâti un système bancaire très
solide
ce système bancaire très solide nous a
aidés à traverser la crise actuelle
on va bâtir un système de santé très
solide
la prochaine crise elle sera différente
mais d'avoir un système de santé très
solide ça nous sera utile c'est ça en
réalité a dit certains biens et services
doivent être placées en dehors de la loi
du marché délégué notre alimentation
notre protection notre capacité à
soigner notre cadre de vie est pure
folie non mais vous voulez me piéger oui
c'est le président de la république me
l'a alors peu d'emphase
c'était de l'emphase ne correspond à
rien je vous pose maintenant qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire où va en effet faire un
effort collectif à travers l'impôt pour
le système de santé l'alimentation le
sist le secteur privé a formidablement
marché enfin vous vous lavez mesurer la
performance que représente on parle que
des soignants
oui les soignants était très courageux
mais vous croyez que les caissières de
carrefour ou de casino qui était
derrière leur plexiglas qui sont payés
au smic qui nous ont permis de nous
alimenter elle était aussi courageuse
que les infirmières à certains égards
donc de ct à cet égard le système tel
qu'il fonctionne d'économie de marché a
répondu comme le système public la vraie
leçon de cette affaire c'est qu'il ya eu
2 france il ya eu une france
incroyablement efficace elle pouvait
être privés comme les chaînes de
distribution elle pouvait être publics
comme les services de réanimation et il
ya eu la mauvaise france c'est à dire la
france qui a poussé l'art de la
réglementation jusqu'aux confins de
l'absurde comme on ne l'avait jamais vu
c'est à dire la mauvaise frangialli
stration la police
les cinquante pages envoyée au directeur
des cow boys solitaires protocole
sanitaire
c'est alors c'est et ça c'est la tension
réelle entre les deux france notre
question c'est comment déplacer un peu
là le fléau de la balance la bonne ou la
mauvaise france qui qui porte plainte
contre le gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est
inacceptable on entre dans une logique
si vous voulez on ne peut pas être 21
oui mais c'est tellement facile de
déposer plainte
je veux dire tonnes vous déposez plainte
vous avez le droit et dans ce cas là on
veut créer quoi
l'inhibition des dirigeants veut dire la
responsabilité politique sauf faute
grave pénale avéré la responsabilité
était politique
elle est politique la france est un des
rares pays à connaître ce dérapage là
qui participent de l'atmosphère
populiste ambiante et qui n'est pas le
meilleur côté de la société française on
va s'intéresser quand même aux
entreprises qui souffrent
particulièrement le secteur de la
restauration
racontez nous un petit peu où on est où
en est le combat vous avez ouvert depuis
lundi dernier
comment ça s'est passé qu'est ce qu'on
vous dit
que vous disent vos collègues autour de
vous on n'a pas pu tout ouvrir lundi
puisque nous faisons
une cuisine priori de qualité avec nos
artisans termeer et on a ouvert nos
premiers établissements mercredi le
temps de remettre en place nos jus que
nous faisons nous même de réceptionner
la marchandise de la volaille du poisson
frais le lundi a pas de poisson donc
nous on a réouvert mercredi on est
enthousiaste on est heureux et les
équipes
moi j'étais ravi de retrouver donc
c'était c'était vraiment une
- une nouvelle étape puisque la première
était est et était lourde mais ces deux
nouvelles étapes on attendait donc ouais
stefan mani gosse je rappelle quand même
vous êtes restaurateur mais vous avez
gagné un combat un combat contre une
compagnie d'assurances laquelle pour la
nommer très précisément du site et axa
met à la c'était actionner un principe
lorsqu'il ya un contraste que les
assureurs ne jouaient pas le jeu
vous avez gagné ça en première instance
est ce que vous avez fait des émules
oui d'autres vont parfaire monde entier
la décision elle a été commentée publié
de chine au canada en irlande en amène
partout parce que partout dans le monde
entier
des commerces ont fermé on confinement
de la population et on s'est penché sur
nos contrats alors j'ai entendu l'appel
de tomates de dollars le président d'axa
qui a suite à la décision de justice
fait appel et c'est le choix fait le
choix d'ouvrir le dialogue
et enfin nous avons un sérieux dialogue
qui s'est installé et je ne peux que
saluer si les assureurs avaient joué le
jeu dès le départ vous pensez que vous
auriez eu moins besoin de l'aide de
l'état
il risque le risque qu'il est il est
puissant il est unique
certainement mais est ce que réellement
on aurait pu tout tout prendre en charge
ou en tout cas l'état l'a fait et c'est
l'état qui en dernier ressort c'est la
constitution française qui le prévoit
donc oui les assureurs doivent prendre
en charge et l'état n'a pas
effectivement se substituer aux contrats
de droit privé et ça c'est une certitude
à la remarque est ce que l'état doit
aider encore plus ce secteur
particulièrement touché philippe
etchebest le chef étoilé
tim à 30% le nombre de restaurants qui
font faillite dans le pays le chiffre on
n'en sait rien il est évident que ce qui
a été fait c'est de maintenir en vie à
travers des prêts le secteur mais il ya
un moment où les prêts ne suffisent pas
il ya un problème qui se posera de fonds
propres je suis absolument convaincu que
un deuxième effort sera fait quand on
aura en tête les perspectives et je
pense et monsieur manigold est un de
ceux qui pue par sa position publique a
contribué que la france vient de faire
une petite découverte qui est pas sans
importance
elle a découvert que le secteur du
tourisme en france près au sens large
représente autant d'un produit intérieur
que l'industrie que l'industrie vous
tourner autour de 10 % l'autre 8 à 10%
industrie c'est 10% et donc je pense que
ce qui vient de se passer est un mal
pour un bien
la france profité du tourisme sans s'en
rendre compte je pense que désormais
elle aura une politique de toury
ferrante différentes et que ça ce sera
un des acquis positifs dans toute crise
il ya des acquis négatif des acquis
positifs
de quoi vous avez souffert le plus est
ce que c'était les loyers exorbitants
est ce que c'est la peur de devoir
rembourser un prêt avec de l'argent
qu'on sait qu'on n'aura pas est-ce que
c'est ces assurances
c'est un global en fait on nous a
demandé de fermer en trois heures et moi
j'ai démarré ma vie de jeune chef
d'entreprise mois de mars 2020 donc j'ai
ouï gizeh était mon entreprise le 16
mars j'étais confortablement installé
dans une grande entreprise des sièges
automobiles
vous avez été le cheval exemple vous
avez été allègrement d'épicier
là c'était voilà j'ai fait mon stage
ouvrier tout de suite sur les aides
précisément qu'est ce que vous attendez
je vous ai écouté attentivement tout à
l'heure il y à des êtres qui était mis
en place des reports de crédits des
reports un prêt garanti par l'état cette
crise elle aura duré trois mois par son
confinement
trois mois c'est pour nous disant de
remboursement jeu
ces trois mois de pertes d'activités
aucune entreprise ne peut supporter le
choc et vous rajoutez à cela au delà des
trois mois à l'ouverture une
distanciation physique qui fait aussi
une réduction de chiffre d'affaires vous
pourrez être un peu plus précis
globalement les entreprises les mieux
gérées dans notre secteur de la
restauration
c'est 10% de marge
enfin aller 10% la plupart elles se
situent entre 1 et 3%
vous voyez bien que la nos marges et
sont fondamentalement donc clairement
vous vous réclamer l'annulation du
remboursement des prêts garantis par
l'état des suppressions de charge
vous pourriez en parler à vous et de
vous c'est bien curieuse demi relations
publiques
non mais vous agency pas la tête pour
vous poser un vrai problème est
évidemment et il faudra agir alors est
ce que ce sera sous cette forme faudra
fait des fonds propres mais ça sera pour
quoi pour la raison que j'ai dit c'est à
dire on a découvert ce qui est
ahurissant dans le premier pays
touristique du monde on a découvert
c'était un secteur d'activité majeur
on est capable de créer de l'emploi mais
bien sûr j'ai participé et écouter les
débats notamment sur la tva à 5,5
lorsque françois fillon a baissé par
exemple de 19,6 à 5,5 sur le sur la
restauration je suis favorable à une
baisse de tva 5,5 conditionnée par le
sourcing donc nous achats de matières
premières auprès de nos artisans termeer
français c'est 98 milliards d'acheter
local des productions d'affaires serait
de 90 milliards
c'est une piste intéressante j'aimerais
vous faire réagir sur un effet pervers
de cette de cette crise
duco vide même s'il est limité il ya des
effets d'aubaine
il faut le dire on va voir s'ils sont
importants pas vous nous direz il ya des
effets d'aubaine lié à toutes ces aides
reçues par des entreprises rabita a mené
l enquête
le 12 mars dernier emmanuel macron
ouvrait les vannes du chômage partiel
tout sera mis en oeuvre pour protéger
nos salariés et pour protéger nos
entreprises
quoi qu'il en coûte là aussi trois mois
plus tard l'heure est à la chasse aux
fraudeurs ce qu'on a mis en place avec
mon ministère c'est un système de
contrôle assez intensif il y aura plus
de 50000 contrôle d'ici cinquante mille
contrôle d'ici la fin de l'été par ce
dispositif inédit
l'état paye 84 % du salaire net des
employés du secteur privé
lorsqu'il n'y a plus d'activité dans
l'entreprise coût du dispositif 25
millions d'euros 8,6 millions de
salariés en ont bénéficié
certaines entreprises en ont abusé c'est
le cas de la maison d'édition ou léa et
chef de projet depuis 6h30 à hyères nous
a annoncé qu'on allait partir en
confinement et qu'il allait assurer
notre salaire niveau de salaire habituel
et c'est nous les gars entière dans la
mesure du possible
non y'a aucun cadre n'a été posé aucune
directive il nous a rien dit du tout on
est juste parti chez nous voilà si ce
n'est que deux jours plus tard on a reçu
en fait un message de sa part nous
indiquant qu'on est en télétravail et
non pas en chômage partiel et qu'il
fallait qu'on travaille pour terminer
numéro de revue d'apparaître
et pourtant à la fin du mois surprise
elle découvre sur sa fiche de paye que
son entreprise la déclarer au chômage
partiel abusé de l'état alors que la
situation était quand même cataclysmique
et c'est rohff a vraiment vraiment
dégueulasse c'est un but l'a conforté
dans mes bottes sur la maman que je
parte
les patrons soupçonné d'avoir abusé du
système sont soumis aux enquêtes des
inspecteurs de la direction régionale
des entreprises 1800 employés sont à
pied d'oeuvre dans toute la france est
passée au peigne fin les déclarations de
chômage partiel donc là on a demandé à
l'entreprise le justifier le no 10 dans
l'application dédiée où on a plusieurs
types de fraude on a des salariés qui
ont été mis au chômage partiel mais
acquis leur employeur a demandé de
continuer à travailler c'est ce dont on
parle le plus on a aussi des employeurs
qui nous ont fait défaut c'est à dire
qu'ils nous ont déclaré des salariés qui
n'existe pas ou qui ont gonflé les
salaires à l'occasion du chômage partiel
puisqu'il était pris en charge c'est une
bonne opération
et puis on a aussi des employeurs qui
ont employé des salariés pour les mettre
immédiatement chômage partiel ce qui
évidemment n'a aucune justification à
peu près sur 20 % de dossiers sur
lesquels on a un petit doute sur ces 20
% de dossiers on en a un certain nombre
sur lequel quand on regarde en fait y'a
pas de problème est une très très grosse
majorité qui se résout en droit à
l'erreur c'est à dire une erreur de
saisie ou entreprises ont dit oui
effectivement j'ai bien vu que j'ai
touché trop d'argent je vous rembourse a
pas de problème on s'arrête là c'est pas
de la fraude caractérisée
les fraudeurs risquent jusqu'à 30000
euros d'amendé et deux ans de prison
ferme
il faut être là câble avec les fraudeurs
oui parce que il faut pas non plus
penser que l'un certain nombre de brebis
galeuses peuvent effacer les forts quand
même incroyable que les chefs
d'entreprise ont fait c'est marginal
votre genou c'est inexistant et
évidemment c'est un véritable messie se
mettre à la marge
vraiment merci merci stéphane manigold
je vous garde avec moi à la main merci
de l'avoir témoigner de votre combat on
va parler à présent de celui qui de tous
nos présidents de la république porte
sans doute le mieux le titre de père de
la nation j'ai nommé le général de
gaulle celui vous voyez c'est évidemment
emmanuel macron
qui était au mont valérien ce matin puis
à londres aux côtés du prince charles
vous le voyez 80 ans jour pour jour
après l'appel du 18 juin 1940 un appel
lancé à la bbc qui vous le savez
sûrement n'a pas été enregistrée sur le
moment je vous propose de le revivre
par la magie du documentaire le jour où
de gaulle a choisi la guerre signé
laurent joffrin qui nous rejoint tout de
suite au fil de la journée
de gaulle réécrit donc son discours à
plusieurs reprises avant de lui dicter à
elisabeth de miribel une secrétaire de
l'ambassade de france qui la veille a
décidé de rejoindre ce qui n'est pas
encore la france libre à 18 heures en
fin de gaulle se tient son texte à la
main devant un micro de la bbc
personne encore ne mesurent l'importance
du moment
l'appel ne sera d'ailleurs même pas
enregistré les chefs qui depuis de
nombreuses années sont à la tête des
armées françaises ont formé un
gouvernement
ce gouvernement alléguant la défaite de
nos armées s'est mis en rapport avec
l'ennemi pour cesser le combat
cette guerre n'est pas tranchée par la
bataille de france
cette guerre est une guerre mondiale
toutes les fautes
tous les retards toutes les souffrances
n'empêchent pas qu'il y a dans l'univers
tous les moyens nécessaires pour écraser
un jour nos ennemis
foudroyés aujourd'hui par la force
mécanique nous pourrons vaincre dans
l'avenir par une force mécanique
supérieure
le destin du monde est là quoi qu'il
arrive
la flamme de la résistance française ne
doit pas s'éteindre et ne s'éteindra pas
bonsoir laurent joffrin c'est donc vous
qui signé ce documentaire qui a été
remporté avec le remporte qui sera
diffusée ce soir un peu tard il a été en
prime en prime time hier soir mais sont
à 00h30 ce soir ainsi qu'évidemment sur
le site de la chaîne parlementaire alors
comme ça vous aussi vous avez cédé à la
dengue ou de manière vous l'homme de
gauche a bossé c'est le double de la
guerre c'est de gaulle pour sensuelle
aujourd'hui tout le monde d'accord avec
personne
pratiquement personne n'est d'accord
avec lui mais maintenant tout le monde
savait assez chaud en retrouvant les
jours d'avant ça tu appelles retraçant
les coulisses cet appel à la bbc on
s'est concentré sur le 16 juin puisqu'il
la décision a été prise le 16 juin
quand quand il a vu que le maréchal
pétain prenait le pouvoir et qu' il
allait faire le discours de l'armistice
il a il est parti et c'est ça la rupture
lieu ce jour-là pas le 18 juin c'est la
suite de la décision mais la décision
est lui à bordeaux ce jour là même nom
enregistré un autre discours se met-il
en même temps il voulait passer ce
message il voulait prendre date contre l
éteindre sait que contre contre
l'envahisseur
oui la france était complètement
effondré et la plupart des gens
pensaient qu'il fallait il fallait
composer vous avec l'ennemi et donc il
était un des seuls à dire n'en était pas
seulement fin il était vraiment le le
plus déterminé et ce qui est incroyable
c'est qu'il était prêt c'est ça qui est
qui dans sa biographie qui est fascinant
c'est que il était près celle mais prêt
prêt c'est-à-dire que il savait pourquoi
comment et quel discours tenir quels
arguments utilisés
et puis il avait ce cette facilité
littéraire c'était le magicien des mots
et ça s'est un peu perdu en politique
malheureusement mais lui était un cesser
ses biographes salue ce temps les
enfants qui rappelle l'artiste de la
politique l'artiste
de décrivent s'est calé à la main que
vous racontez fait le premier chapitre
vous avez confié beaucoup de présidents
mais pas celui là forcément vous vous
êtes au fond devenue quelque part
admirateur du général de gaulle je n'ose
dire gaulliste mais en tout cas vous ne
venez pas de ce cette école de monza non
non je suis né dans une famille qui
était très loin de saint puisqu'une
parents étaient communistes et je me
souviens d avoir entendu le soir du
référendum de septembre 58 se dire je
sais pas ce que ça voulait vraiment dire
j'avais 9 ans se dire ah là là il faut
s'habituer à vivre désormais sous une
dictature majeur alors après je me suis
relativement émancipé en devenant mains
des cistes mais j'aurais dû être
gaulliste veux dire ma des six le mende
et 6 mai c'était la version tiède de
scorer et et le gaullisme
non mais je suis d'accord avec tout ce
que laurent a dit le hasard de la vie ce
fait que je suis très lié depuis très
très longtemps à la famille à la famille
de geoffroy de courcel et c'est quelque
chose de très z très étonnant parce que
c'est la rame était le deuxième vers
l'avion c'est l aide de camp du général
qui l'accompagnent et en remettant à son
fils la légion d'honneur j'ai dit ça
doit être bien difficile d'être le fils
du deuxième homme du 17 juin
du 17 juin dans l'avion c'est
surréaliste c'est un épisode
inimaginable il ya que lui réclame
aujourd'hui mais c'est un peu ridicule
pourquoi pour le 18 juin qu'ont ils à
sauver l'honneur
enfin c'est le mec un virus qu'on ait la
guerre mais séduit la sauver l'honneur
rendu sa place à la france le des
vainqueurs salle à la performance
alors qu'ils n'avaient rien ou très peu
de choses mais par la suite toutes les
forces politiques qui lui rendent
hommage aujourd'hui l'ont combattue de
son vivant
c'est pas la même personne évidemment
mais c'est les même partis parti
communiste était très hostile le général
de gaulle au parti socialiste aussi pas
au début tout à fait de la 5e mais après
oui de temps chaud surtout quand il a
été dirigé par françois maison et les
centristes et se méfier de gaulle parce
qu'ils étaient européens les deux vols
les témoins il y avait que le rpr plus
rap fr père idéal c'est la série d'aidés
parti gaulliste qui le soutenaient tous
les autres étaient contre lui à la plus
ridicule c'est le front national
j'espère garder cette image de marine le
pen qui a finalement c'est rendu non pas
le 18 mai le 17 sur l'île de sein la
voilà elle était évidemment mal venu sur
cette île du coup elle a changé son
calendrier
elle avait le droit d'y aller c'est vrai
mais elle a essuyé quelques quelques
sifflets quand vous voyez cette image là
le pen qui va qui va dans cet endroit là
ce haut lieu symbolique de la résistance
qu'est ce que vous pensez mais je veux
aller lui imputer les opinions ou les
fautes de son père qui en est
responsable n'est pas responsable de ses
parents est ce parce que leur assemblée
nationale c'est quand même le bébé du
front national c'est la même chose
les idées sont à peu près les mêmes le
père lui était un ennemi juré du général
et lisse et c'était 1
il était pétainiste rétrospectivement et
surtout il était pour conserver
l'algérie et et colonialiste lula comme
dans le temps de le louper un langage de
jean marie le pen largué avant donné le
jet le nom ce qui ce qui me gêne le plus
c'est que le discours du recensement
national c'est un discours de comment
dire de crainte
la france est en déclin et il faut se
barricader faut se protéger de jean loup
ne jamais les choses pareilles il n'en a
même pas eu l'idée pour lui la france
est une c'est la grandeur donc c'est la
projection vers tirs sur la scène
d'ouverture sur le monde
jarle n'aurait jamais eu l'idée par
exemple de remettre en cause le droit du
sol humide est utile et qu'il paraissait
babson c'est le rassembleur aussi que
l'on vient chercher quand on essaye
comme ça
de s'imprégner du général de se placer
dans ses pas je crois que le vrai
reproche à faire à marine le pen est pas
responsable en effet de son père et elle
peut sur demain sujet d'ailleurs sont
éloignés je pense qu'elle a fait sur
l'antisémitisme autres mais dans celle
dans ce cas là qu'elle extrait et
qu'est-ce qu'elle élimine son parti de
son idéologie tout ce qui est l'héritage
quand même de la longue ligne de
l'extrême droite française veut dire
c'est quand même
cette extrême droite là qui a soutenu en
réalité loes s'est extrait que le trade
de donc je pense est diabolisé suède a
pas fait assez mais là je pense qu'elle
essaye de le faire à la surface des
choses parce que si elle se met à
extraire les racines profondes de son
parti je sais pas ce qui reste je pars
très partie de ceux qui pensaient
qu'elle peut conquérir le pouvoir
tout est malheureusement possible mais
d'une certaine façon je crois que le
populisme peut conquérir le pouvoir mais
que marine le pen porte en elle même une
capacité d'un pilote de la part de la
population
mais il existe un petit risque ça sera
une élection veut dire il ya un bouquet
très simple elle passe de 20% en 2010
est à 34 son père en son père passe de
je suis plus combien de but de 18 à 20
donc ils viennent de quelque part les
14%
elle monte à 45 1 dans les derniers
sondages en intentions de vote si
l'élection avait lieu demain je vais
vous montrer cette de gaulle magna à
l'assemblée personne n'était pas renié
si j'ose dire c'est thomas des prêts qui
va nous raconter ça oui exactement
myriam en cette journée anniversaire
nous on a voulu savoir s'il existait des
députés qu il se revendiquait pas du
général de gaulle eh bien figurez vous
que c'est pas facile à trouver
c'est ma journée à l'assemblée
alors vous avez peut-être vu ces images
de marine le pen la présidente du
rassemblement national député du pas de
calais hier soir rendant hommage au
général de gaulle aujourd'hui tout le
monde ou presque se dit gaulliste mais
nous on a voulu savoir si ici à
l'assemblée nationale il y avait des
députés non gaullisme on les a cherchés
et c'est pas facile à trouver
est ce que vous vous êtes gaullisme oui
gaulliste de gauche
oui je suis gaulliste profondément
gaulliste je ne peux qu être gaulliste
je pense que nous sommes très nombreux à
être gaulliste
est-ce que vous rendrez chassaigne vous
êtes gaulliste je ne suis pas gaulliste
mais j'ai du respect vous vous
revendiquez pas du général de gaulle je
suis pas gaulliste suis socialiste c'est
pas difficile d'être tout seul pas
gaulliste finalement dans une assemblée
où tout le monde se dit gaulliste
non j'ai l'habitude d'être tout seul
pour défendre un certain nombre de
dispositions et de propositions
politiques avec mon groupe dans
l'hémicycle donc non on finit par s'y
habituer ce que j'espère en tout cas
c'est ne plus l'être et qu'on soit bien
plus nombreux la fois suivante pourquoi
pas majoritaires là ça changerait les
choses
bon alors avant que les députés non
gaullistes ne devienne majoritaire à
l'assemblée nous on a demandé pourquoi
les députés empruntent tous l'image du
général de gaulle
comment l'as fait qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde se revendique du général de gaulle
ça ne vous a pas échappé
les idéologies ont un peu disparu des
débats on ne parle plus sur le fond
aujourd'hui on parle sur la forme est
difficile de trouver des points de
repère et donc le général de gaulle et
n'est plus là donc c'est assez simple
pour celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'idées d'aller chercher loin
ses points de repères je pense que le
général de gaulle était clairement ancré
dans des valeurs de droite par essence
et par nature nous sommes les seuls
gaulliste de paysage politique français
création pense que le gaullisme
n'appartient plus à personne en propre
ni à aucun parti
alors vu que le général de gaulle
appartient à tout le monde on leur a
tous demandé quels étaient ses plus
grandes qualités et ses éventuels
défauts qu'il avait une qualité serait
laquelle l'amour de la france l'amour de
la france
la sobriété la résistance - voilà c'est
la première qui me faisait un esprit
évidemment beaucoup de qualités mais une
en particulier la participation et un
défaut ne pas en avoir
orgueil quoi qu'il était facilement
irascible là j'ai du mal à dire quels
défauts on peut trouver au général de
gaulle un défaut j'ai pas connu gerin de
gaulle il est trop grand il parle
d'amour de la france également
voilà meriem quoi qu'il en soit cette
année c'est l'année de gauche donc on
aura forcément l'occasion d'en reparler
dans ma journée à l'assemblée alors est
la main que ça vous fait sourire
finalement est-ce que c'est pas devenu
une marque les râles de gaulle quand on
devient jeanne d'arc de gaulle
maintenant ça relève de de cela plus que
de l'univers politique et alain minc le
goal être gaulliste être gaullien la
différence on peut être gaullien sans
être gaulliste être gaulliste est une
adhésion politique même électorale à
l'action du général de gaulle est de
gaulle l'insee se référer à une attitude
en forme de charisme le plus gaullien de
la liste la part de peur de gaulle sur
enel macron certains s'essayent soit
mitterrand françois mitterrand vous
derrière la même chose oui je veux plus
gaullien résidence d'été mais mon but il
habille c'était un peu le sang chaud
prendre ça après don quichotte donc à
nous poser mon mitterrand oui parce
qu'il avait ce côté littéraire un pirate
iq et leur contrat presque on le sait et
demi ont toujours dit il était également
dans la résistance contre moi un peu
tardivement un peu beaucoup moins vite
qu'au journaliste laurent joffrin sur à
la main que vous connaissez bien oui il
est beau jouer les droites
après un parcours comme ça avoir
conseillé au dessus de 30 ans ça dépend
de gauche parce que j'ai un vieux
socialisme mais il n'est pas non plus
vraiment de droite
entre les deux un allez vous aurez le
mois de la fin droit de réponse non non
mais je suis couvert par ce que dit
laurent donc je m'en tiens là merci
merci à tous les deux on va à présent
rejoindre et je vous promets de vous
libérer parce que je vais promis que
vous serez alors on va rejoindre camille
saféris pour son rendez vous du jeudi
bonsoir camille avec qui vous avez pris
un verre
ce soir qui parmi les parlementaires
vous nous fait découvrir
bonsoir myriam ce soir j'ai bu un verre
avec sabine qui dit elle est députée en
marche d'indre et loire
je les rangs
montré au café néon à paris dans le 18e
alors sabine trier c'est une franco
allemand d'une europhile convaincu le
fait d'être binational est bien
évidemment c'est un plus natürlich ce
qui m'a frappé d'abord c'est ses
lunettes très branché très fashion avec
une seule branche rouge elles sont
vendues à tous par un petit opticien de
quartier vous allez me dire pourquoi je
vous parle de ses lunettes
et bien c'est peut-être moins innocent
que vous le pensez on regarde la
construction européenne par exemple avec
le net française les allemands avec
leurs lunettes l'allemande les italiens
avec la lunette italien un sac c'est
important de le faire parce que voilà et
temps en temps il faudra enlever nos
lunettes chaussées ceux de l'autre
pouvoir qu'est ce que ça donne aucun
autre est mieux que vous êtes stigmates
ah bah oui mais comme ça on voit ce que
ça donne être myope astigmate c'est sale
et en même temps et qu'on aurait besoin
peut-être on a d'autres besoins et on ne
peut pas niveler voilà alors donc pour
samitier les lunettes c'est important
mais aussi le fait d'être bi national
dont lingue parce que en politique ça
peut aussi être une richesse aouij à
penser de plusieurs manières à la fois
chaque langue à sa logique
l'allemand par exemple l inverse à la
fin ça vous oblige à davantage d'écouté
de l'autre parce qu'il faut que pour
bien comprendre ce qu'il vous dira il
accueille que tes concerts parfois
tendance au bout du troisième mot de
vous interrompre parce qu'il sait déjà
ce que vous voulez dire même si vous
voulez éventuellement dire autre chose
la théorie qui est très différente
lalande conditionne une certaine logique
et une certaine manière de penser avoir
plusieurs logiques c'est quand même
aussi plus de chance de trouver une
solution alors sous ses dehors très
urbain et bien sabine tiller est aussi
une rural à sa façon et quand elles
rentrent chez elles et bien c'est une
autre femme qui aime aussi le quotidien
et sa rusticité car elle jardin mais oui
quand je suis chez moi j'adore jardinier
m'occuper de mes poules et vous avez des
poules j'ai lépaule sait combien de
poule 4 maintenant 4 d'ailleurs rappelle
comment les empâtements ont tiré le
coultre rad rousse des poules pondeuses
qu'est ce que vous leur donner à manger
à beaucoup elle reste les épluchures
tout le reste n'aurait pas être trahi
dans les croûtes de fromage par exemple
quand vous mangez pas ce que vous mangez
beaucoup de fromages vous non mais en
dehors du forum en aiment le fromage
accord ne mange pas trop long quand vous
mangez les oeufs de vos poules est ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'ils ont
pas le même goût parce que c'est vos
poules de toute façon ils n'ont pas le
même goût suivant ce qui est dans vos
restants si vous avez plus de croûtes de
fromages ou +2 ou des restes de
crevettes par exemple alors les
crevettes choses comme ça arrivent à
vous pouvez tout à fait retrouvé un
petit goût de
de quelque chose au toit dans le ciel
alors pour finir comme je l'avais sous
la main j'ai demandé à savigné de nous
faire un petit spot de promo pour lcp à
destination de nos spectateurs
germanophone et les couper en lamelles
ces traductions elle a parlé de vous
camille saféris merci et à jeudi à jeudi
leur charge de trail chronique à google
à faire de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve en début de semaine prochaine
mardi prochain très précisément très
belle soirée sur s&p
[Musique]